out beyond Jupiter lies Saturn a planet
circled by multiple moons and rings it's
like a miniature solar system
imagine having a mission with the power
the instruments the capability to
explore all aspects of the Saturn system
that mission was Cassini
[Music]
it would become our eyes and ears in the
Saturnian system for over 13 years
but by September 2017 Cassini is almost
out of fuel Cassini has been orbiting
Saturn studying the Saturn system for
over a decade and the mission we're
gonna lose control soon so rather than
let it just go derelict we headed into
Saturn go out with a bang
[Applause]
the Cassini team goes for broke they
programmed the probe to head straight
for the planet
how cool is it to sort of sacrifice
everything you've got to sort of learn
your last bit of information and then
crash and burn
as Cassini was careening toward its
death it still had instruments that
continued to work and as each instrument
died there were still a set sending back
data and information Cassini
wasn't designed to plunge through
Saturn's atmosphere
no one knew how long it would last
before burning up
I remember sitting in a room with my
colleagues on Cassini and watching that
radio signal that sharp green peak that
told us Cassini was still linked to the
earth we could monitor the atmosphere as
we flew into it I'm right up until the
last it was sending back signs I was
really impressed by how long Cassini
lasted in the Saturn atmosphere I mean
go NASA engineering that's Cassini
plummeted down at 77,000 miles an hour
it was bombarded by gas molecules and
Saturn's atmosphere
friction started tearing Cassini apart
as it struggled to maintain contact
as the antenna turned away we actually
saw a secondary little peak and we
thought okay Cassini hang in there keep
fighting and then just that green flat
line
[Music]
Cassini's heartbeat was gone and we knew
the mission had ended it just vaporized
in the Saturnian atmosphere and so it
has become a part of Saturn itself
[Music]
Cassini's death plunge was the last of a
series of daring dives prior to ending
Cassini's mission by sending it into
Saturn's atmosphere NASA's engineers and
scientists came up with an idea Les Deux
dives into the region between the tops
of Saturn's clouds and animals area of
Saturn's rings beginning in April of
2017
Cassini ventured between Saturn and its
rings 22 times scientists called it the
grand finale
on these dives Cassini got closer to
Saturn's cloud tops than any spacecraft
ever had before
Saturn is an enormous ball of hydrogen
and helium a gas giant fundamentally
it's a really very different kind of
planet than we're used to in our
everyday lives
Cassini snaps close ups of the planet's
gaseous surface the pictures reveal a
turbulent and stormy world we think of
some storms on earth is being
particularly violent if you've ever been
in a hurricane that's not a fun place to
be but the storms on Saturn the wind
patterns on Saturn can make that look
like a mere Breeze in comparison on
Saturn one storm stands out its location
is marked by a distinct shape one of the
really weird things is that where's the
bands go around Saturn they're all
circular until you get to the pole and
then there's a hexagonal band up there
no one expected that during its lifetime
Cassini took multiple images of the
hexagon whenever we posted an image of
the hexagon that hits to the website
went through the roof I think people
thought it was so mysterious when I
first saw this I was blown away I mean
who could imagine having something this
regular almost geometric on the
atmosphere of a planet it's really just
phenomenal
in 2018 Cassini data reveals this
hexagonal storm could be a towering
structure hundreds of miles in height
it's this gigantic structure it's many
thousands of miles across and right in
the center right at the pole is this
sort of permanent vortex of permanent
hurricane so it's kind of a creepy
I like thing staring back at us each
side of the hexagon is as wide as the
earth it seems artificial how do you get
a hexagon shaped storm or cloud
structure on Saturn scientists think
that Saturn's spin interacts with air
currents to create this symmetrical
shape but they don't know why it's
lasted for decades that's the puzzle how
can you get a six-sided jet stream
that's stable for so long but while the
hexagon shape is stable the color has
altered over for years it changed from
mostly blue to golden brown
the transformation is linked to Saturn's
seasons the seasons on Saturn are caused
by the same thing on earth it's the tilt
of the planet and so a Saturn is going
around the Sun and its North Pole is
tipping toward the Sun you start to get
more light up there this sunlight
interacts with the atmosphere producing
suspended particles called aerosols
actually looks a lot like smog it turns
things more orange so over time the
hexagon went from blue to orange the
color change happened during one of
Saturn's Northern Hemisphere's summers
but mysteriously the very center of the
hexagon remained blue now this could
have been for two reasons
maybe the haze never formed in the eye
because the eye was shielded from the
Sun and the Sun is responsible for
creating the brownish haze that we see
on Saturn another reason is maybe the
actual vortex is sucking the haze down
maybe there's something like the eye of
a hurricane
there's haze that forms over it but it
gets sucked down into the eye
but the storms on Saturn aren't the only
extraordinary thing about the weather
when Cassini dives through the Rings it
discovers rain rain falling onto the
planet from space
[Applause]